[Music]
sorry jerk
um
sorry now you know what you know what i
was going to play something i felt like
that was literally you know i was i feel
like that was a little unwarranted i was
going to play something fun but you know
what i'm going to play instead now
merch you could blame virgie for this
[Music]
no
no i'm already realizing what this is no
no
no
this is the new banger
this is the new day wave banger
no
no is that the drummer is that the
drummer from from offspring yes yes okay
well the drummer from the offspring
after the offspring didn't matter
anymore like he got in the band in oh
wait that's like oh so that's that's not
that's not like crazy taxi
oh no okay that's that's like
that's really taxi offspring yeah that's
this this guy's more of my friend's got
a girlfriend and he hates that [ __ ]
tony hawk's pro skater attack or [ __ ]
officer
okay got it and now this is a pretty fly
for a white guy offspring okay
i can't i can't do this
shut up
this is this is going to be
look at this
i can't i can't i don't want to do this
no you got to
you [ __ ] you weak
weak
is just never gonna be happy with who he
is
he hates his lot in life man he can't
just be the annoying little [ __ ]
south park character who wants to debate
everybody about everything the
contrarian nerd he hates it he's super
successful and now he's going to dump
his [ __ ] youtube money into these
[ __ ] vanity projects and he's just
going to embarrass himself
i don't know why he wants to meet his
dead in 2022.
doesn't want to be seo said in 2022.
that is not really how he sings
wait wait till he hears well no it's
really not how he sings because that's
how he sings after it's been put through
[ __ ] melody's auto tune because this
is [ __ ] absolutely auto-tuned like a
[ __ ] bro all right let's do it i
can't do this
it's really really good can i ask a
question
yeah please what is up with this guy's
head
dude i i swear to god race i swear to
[ __ ] god i paused it at the same
exact moment and i asked the same age he
looks he looks like he just discovered
fire
dude i did this i did this on my stream
last night
look at the eye look at the brow dude he
looks like he can see his eyebrows
he looks like the humans in the original
warcraft oh my god yes yes exactly
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] work
who's this guy anyway
i have no idea i didn't look i didn't
look this up because i just he's got
enough problems man i just figured what
is his fault what having a having such a
big brow but a three and a half head
yeah i get it i mean he's a [ __ ] crow
magnet man bro like [ __ ]
he looks like he looks like he he looks
like phil hartman's lawyer caveman
lawyer character yeah
look i might just be a caveman
of course when i look at the moon i just
think monkeys are eating it it's so good
it's easy when i'm lying there with you
oh oh bye hey merge it's a love song
yeah i could tell who's this
who is this woman some ugly said
somebody actually hired and that tim
will probably awkwardly hit on
[Music]
this was just a bunch of money spent so
tim pool could feel like a big shot on
him on a music video set hey hey
it's gonna be a whole album
i honestly do look forward to it like i
do look forward to having an entire
album release party it's gonna be great
we should throw a tin pool album release
party
like here in florida and just like find
a small like bar that'll let us have
like we'll sell tickets and some of our
fans can just come hang out and we'll
get some like comedians to do some [ __ ]
too but then we'll just literally
because could we even get sued for that
sirach just donated so raj just donated
five bucks on rumble and said let tim
pool cook
[Laughter]
but no seriously
would we get sued yes yes yes yes
knowing the back and forth that happened
between tim and his brother we will get
sued oh yeah good point 100 percent dude
100 we will get sued
because it would be funny to be like no
but we were just doing a show
celebrating your album we didn't now
nothing could stop us from having a
get-together and playing his entire
album we could do that but we just can't
promote it as tim poole's album release
party we could say tim poole what if we
said i got it
official yes album release
unofficial fan club
album release
party celebration of album in delta
in pensacola
in pensacola yes i don't know i just
wanted a weird place pensacola's weird
i mean it's cool little town i guess
panhandle town we always want to do a
panhandle town anyway
let's do it [ __ ] it do it let's do it
when does this album release
it's already it's today no the whole
album can't be out today no i haven't i
haven't seen i haven't seen merch mercy
all about them can't be released i
haven't seen bodies strewn on the
streets that's true and i haven't seen
it on billboard yet which oh i mean it's
gonna immediately debut
somewhere at the top
we're only 50 seconds in we're playing
the whole [ __ ] song so that's what's
happening now so settle in boys
[Music]
[Music]
this is like it dude
i
i know now what it felt like
for all those muslims in those cia black
site prisons i was just thinking i now
know what what they've like all those
sheiks that just were getting
waterboarded and tortured hey hey siraj
i know you're listening we apologize to
your people i i mean now we know the
pain you people felt you had a good
point yeah i'm sorry man for you know
voting for bush yeah seriously
i'm not sorry for the first time in the
second time i'm sorry second time for
sure i feel bad the quote i must i'm
sorry i did that
i shouldn't have done that
i'm ready to rock
[Music]
like you know there was a sound engineer
in there how do you record a podcast
with tim pool and keep a straight face i
mean at that at least it's like any of
them do
yeah i mean but this is next level do
like i couldn't imagine just sitting
there as the sound engineer and being it
had to be as awkward as [ __ ] dirk
diggler's sound engineer in boogie
nights
you got to touch you think it's uh the
bass is overpowering my vocals no it's
fine no no turn the bass down
after all is said and done
[ __ ] the only thing tim paul's
missing is john c reilly in the [ __ ]
engineering booth going you do
okay
somebody somebody make the gif the the
gift but but put um
but put tim pool's face on a mark
wahlberg and put tom mcdonald on john c
riley pointing
please
[Music]
[Applause]
this song is the 90 bridge
better yet no don't make it tom mcdonald
make tim poole on dirk digler's head and
make like the quartering
because the quartering is always sucking
tim pulls dick
hey
did you notice something royce about the
title
uh it's called tim cast dash yeah the
band's name is tim cass that's the name
of the band is tim cast but that's gonna
hurt your seo for your show
uh i'll have you know he used to work
for vice
he has uh everywhere where this is
uploaded on [ __ ] like spotify on all
the all that [ __ ]
all it's uploaded as the band name is
tim cast
did you think i'd walk away
did you think if i hear
one person because this is what's going
to happen and i said it the other day
when we saw the clip and again you're
gonna hear a lot of people going like at
least he's tried something
at least he's tried something you
believed in yeah i tried being in a band
too when i was in [ __ ] junior high
school what was it called
i know what it was called say it
[ __ ] say
called
look little kid it was called
revengeance
he's
hey listen
the difference between me and tim poole
is that i was 13 years old
and tim paul just dresses like a 13 year
old yeah exactly like at least i wasn't
35 and like you know what i think i'm
going to start a band
okay guys hey thank you for listening to
revengeance of the sis
bro
no wonder you named the show this it
makes sense now you know what the worst
part is
it's like we all laugh at that now but
when we were 13 everyone was like oh
that's pretty badass somebody in the
chat somebody in the chat literally said
that's pretty that's pretty cool dude
when you're 14. people are like that's
pretty badass dude imagine that's pretty
cool
it sounds like the name to a matrix
sequel
matrix revengeance
oh
yeah you know the one that they didn't
get
they didn't get
or any of the originals they just got
the lesbian oh [ __ ]
you're getting a lot of sick name bro
sick name bro
[ __ ] awesome
what kind of music
there was a lot of screaming a lot of oh
screamo a lot of angry like a lot of
ripoffy
pantera-ish
where a lot of yelling it was very bad
did you also have the drummer from
offspring
for a little while okay
you'll play with anybody
well because i mean he wouldn't get the
vax that's a good point
[Music]
today
does this song never start
like when does this song start being a
song at some point like in the middle
when the drums kick in
i'm wait i'm wait i'm waiting for in the
air tonight drums to kick it at some
point
i
not even lying all right it starts at
the end
now now i have i have a good uh tom
mcdonald's
tim pool mashup if somebody can do this
sure we got enough people uh 3 400
people watching by the way thank you um
if one of you guys could mesh up the
scene in the sopranos
when hesh is explaining to christopher
about like music and how that band sucks
like he's he literally makes like hesh
listen to the demo for a second and he's
like nah this stinks this is never going
to go anywhere and then at the end of
the episode like hesh walks in or
whatever and he's like giving them an
envelope and he passes christopher and
there's a regular song playing on the
radio and he stops and he's like now
that's a hit and then he just walks out
somebody needs to take the original this
stinks take the music out and put tim
pool's music in for a second and then do
the cut to him leaving and play tom
mcdonald's on the radio so as he leaves
he goes now that's a hit
can i try something
can i can i can i try something let me
try something i think i could do
something hold on i'm gonna do it on the
fly but i think it could make this work
uh
you get this
right the scene which i'm sure you've
seen from the elvis movie you've seen it
right
um with tom hanks he listens i don't
think i saw that movie no not forget the
movie it's just a clip from the movie
okay and it's pretty
i thought you would have seen that
that's been meme to death already they
they they did the white boy summer which
of course makes sense because it's tom
hanks
um that's perfect
do you when this is not a reprieve folks
this is not do you think we're not known
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i bet you you know what he's gonna do
too i mean maybe i'm wrong maybe he
won't and i don't want to accuse him of
something that he hasn't done so let me
be fair here but i really hope that
temple doesn't go around and start
copy not striking but copy claiming
anybody that's doing commentary on this
on youtube you know
not that we're on youtube now i don't
care but i'm just saying you know i'm
worried that's the next
[Music]
step when does the song become a song
is there a verse is there a chorus
is there an angle here no there isn't
there's none of that
you see what you don't understand mercer
is that tim poole is an artist you see
he grew up in chicago
right
what does that have to do with anything
but he stinks i hate you
[Music]
this is supposed to be like a third
single where you can be a little
boring you know what i mean but your
first song should be
your first song should feel like a
three-minute radio song with a hook and
a cat like a catchy hold on hold on it's
it's picking up right now though
honestly i think i think i know verge
you sent by it starts at the end three
minutes in it's a it builds up watts
listen
[Music]
[Music]
i want to drain the main vein prostate
massage so insane until you scream i'm
so [ __ ] gay
gonna [ __ ] though masturbation
ejaculation slaying last season to the
masses face to face and i'll be
fornicating [ __ ] only when i'm busting
out
he's so thick indeed when i'm pumping
already
but don't bring condoms to the queen
it synced so well with the video
tim cass featuring the rock
[Music]
this video [ __ ] sucks
jesus christ tim what are you doing by
the way i love how we all knew the i'm
so [ __ ] like i don't know
anything no that's the high part that's
the hype
oh
part
and that's our review of tim cast who
only ever wanted
[Music]
i hope people enjoyed
you think tim's gonna see this i have a
feeling when i i haven't it's gonna be a
good night why don't we listen to that
song instead i'd rather listen to the to
bangable banker points
i'd rather see that old man dance at six
flags dude we live in a world where tim
poole's making music and we can't get
sky blue and red foo in the same room
anymore that's a good piece you know
what i mean yeah
i'd rather have lmfao back god i know
because at least they were way better
party rock
that's still like one of the most
popular songs of all time of course yeah
party rock
oh
you're gonna beat party rock anthem i
have a few